so the core hypotheses that I'm
developing in my research are that an
inclusive national narrative one that's
based on Creed's
ideas principles that some of you've
read silky Yama's recent work on
identity he calls us credo nationalism
that that all else being equal helps
actually to support democracy whereas an
exclusive national narrative one that's
based on a fixed identities of race
religion caste ethnicity religion being
fixed in most parts of the world as an
identity undermines democracy all else
being equal I mean before I kind of
unpack those hypotheses and what I'm
doing to research and and and and test
these I want to I wanted to spend a
moment on two questions I often get
asked when I present this research so
the first question is am I not really
collapsing the distinction between
patriotism and nationalism right so
isn't patriotism kind of all the good
stuffs about feeling love for one's
country and nationalism all the bad
stuff well no serious scholar that I
know of nationalism actually takes a
distinction very seriously it's a very
big part of the public debate but the
very same actions can look can be
described as patriotic or nationalist
depending on whether you like them or
not and what outcomes you think that
they have but to describe a phenomenon
an analytically it's important not to
describe it based on its consequences
but would be able to describe the font
phenomenon in and of itself and love for
one's country certainly can just be part
of because so patriotism can some
research has shown quite easily slide
into nationalism when the circum went
especially when circumstances of threat
arise the second question I get asked a
lot is wooden isn't the ideal world one
in which we don't have national
identities at all
why celebrate national identities why
why really promote them in some sense if
the ideal world is one in which we all
just are our primary identities are ones
that are based on our common humanity
and the answer I give to that is that um
there's a lot of social psychology
research that shows that human beings
are by their very nature clannish they
need communities and that in fact the
countries around the world that we've
seen that don't have a national identity
they're come closest to not having a
national identity are not utopian but in
fact very dystopian and what you see
here is a picture of Somalia where there
is no clear not national identity at all
so um I go about this research neither
that I'm at the very beginning of this
project so this is a sort of a
relatively light on a lot of evidence
but I'm I'm going to tell you about how
I'm going about this research in in
three domains the first domain is that
I'm looking at sort of to look at like
for like I'm looking at all countries
that gained colonial independence in the
1940s and 50s and 60s and looking at
their founding constitutions and
creating an index of inclusivity based
on such questions as does the preempt of
the Constitution the part that begins
with We the People is there a definition
of the nation that mentions race
religion or region is there a religious
or racial category that's required for
to either be at the head of state or to
serve and an important distinction of
government and using these kinds of
questions I create an inclusive 'ti
index that I'm statistically looking at
whether it has that has a pattern with a
whole bunch of databases that look at
democracy so I'm in the process right
now of putting that together so that's
the first way I do that
the second way that I do that I
investigate the relationship between
nationalism and democracy is that I'm
looking at some experiments which show
that when you look at you ask
individuals how much are you willing to
give to Co ethnics or Co religious
co-religionists in need and then when
you actually prime individuals for
example by showing them a national flag
they're actually the different there
everyone is more likely to give to their
Co ethnics in most contexts but when you
prime them individuals by showing the
national flag they actually are less
likely to want to give to that there
they're equally likely to want to give
to members of their nation so it very
much shows that nationalism is a force
for solidarity and the third way and
that's the what I'm going to talk about
a little bit more tonight is that I'm
looking at countries that are largely
similar so three sets of countries that
are largely similar on those
explanations I gave you but that have
very different national identities that
their founding and I trace over time
whether and how those national
identities get used in moments of crisis
[Music]